l'armonia della natura In un numero
Come è possibile da ingegnere di così è
possibile e da
storico dico sì è possibile e sono qua
proprio per condividere con voi questo
mio pensiero per capire questo dobbiamo
ritornare un attimo indietro
a chi ha creato la natura gli antichi
egizi dicevano che è fosse stata Iside a
cui dedicarono un inno un inno che
terminava con queste parole
Io sono la madre di mio padre
Io sono
la sposa Anzi la sorella di mio marito
ed egli è il mio figlio respinto
rispettatemi
rispettatemi perché da magnifica posso
diventare scandalosa cioè
i Side ci dice che la natura è magnifica
ma
da magnifica qual è Se non rispettata A
questo punto diventa scandalosa Cioè ci
genera un'ansia collettiva
crea disastri come come ben sappiamo gli
antichi egizi
avevano ben chiaro questo problema
quando decisero di fare le loro Piramidi
c'era chi li voleva a Guglia c'era chi
le voleva un po' più schiacciate poi
alla fine compresero
che se l'altezza di una faccia laterale
l'apotema fosse stata il rapporto di 1,6
circa con l'altezza della piramide bene
questa piramide diventava armoniosa e
piaceva a tutti
secoli dopo un signore che si chiamava
Euclide
scoprì esattamente questo numero ed era
1,618 eccetera eccetera eccetera
eccetera un numero di infinite cifre
e questo numero piacque talmente tanto
che lo chiamarono aureo
ancora secoli dopo ci fu un signore un
Pisano un Pisano si chiamava Fibonacci
Fibonacci scoprì che il concetto di
1,618 non è un concetto statico cioè
legato a quella piramide o quell'altra
cosa era un concetto dinamico tutta la
natura evolveva secondo questa legge il
Trend era proprio 1,618 lui lo
rappresentò con una spirale ma forse il
miglior metodo per rappresentarla E
questa rosa perché se guardiamo bene i
suoi Petali Ebbene i suoi Petali
evolvono secondo una spirale e la
spirale è quella di Fibonacci
ancora tempo dopo ci fu un signore che
si chiamava Leonardo da Vinci Leonardo
da Vinci insieme ad un suo amico che si
chiamava Luca paciolli scrissero e
illustrarono un altro testo quest'altro
testo si chiamava the Divina proporzione
studiarono bene a fondo questo numero
1,618 e capirono che facendo centro
nell'ombelico di un essere umano quando
tutte le dimensioni sono nello stesso
rapporto
1,618 Allora il corpo è armonico questo
lo intuì e capi benissimo che si
applicava questo sui suoi quadri
sarebbero stati bellissimi
Questo che vedete è il quadro più visto
al mondo 9 milioni di persone lo vanno a
vedere tutti gli anni
ma aveva capito Leonardo aveva capito un
concetto ancora più bello
una un bambino di due anni posto di
fronte a queste immagini direbbe che è
bella e pure il bambino non ha cultura
non lo sa
come fa è il seme di vino che è lui
che glielo fa dire perché
per questo nacque Divina
proporzione dopo Leonardo ci fu
Botticelli e tanti altri Ovviamente che
seguirono le stesse orme ma ci fu anche
chi non le seguì
Van Gogh non lo eseguì fece altri tipi
di quadri pure questo quadro ogni anno
due milioni di persone vanno ad
Amsterdam a vederlo
E perché se lo guardate bene fatto da
due colori Il blu e il giallo
solamente due colori con le varie
tonalità
Ma perché allora ci piace così tanto
piace a tutti voi
perché ogni colore
è un'onda elettromagnetica è un'onda
elettromagnetica e una frequenza e una
frequenza è un numero
e il giallo e il blu sono due numeri il
cui rapporto è esattamente
1,618 vedete
Leonardo lo aveva studiato
Van Gogh lo aveva dentro di sé non lo
sapeva Non aveva studiato Van Gogh però
tutte e due avevano scoperto una cosa la
forza di questo numero avevano scoperto
come questo numero fosse capace di
gestire i rapporti tra le nostre
sensazioni e l'armonia del mondo che ci
circonda che è una cosa stupenda ma noi
allora come lo gestiamo questo rapporto
questa immagine ci dice uno dei Mille
casi in cui non gestiamo bene questo
rapporto ogni anno 2 miliardi di
tonnellate di cibo lo gettiamo tra i
rifiuti 2 miliardi di tonnellate
e questo non è secondo la natura
E allora che possiamo fare noi che non
siamo Leonardo noi che non siamo Van
Gogh Ma se noi cominciassimo a pensare
in un'altra maniera per esempio se
invece di comprare 10 mele ne
comprassimo 6 scopriremo che quelle
quattro vedi in più in realtà prima o
poi finiscono tra i rifiuti Se invece di
utilizzare 10 volte un elettrodomestico
lo usassimo 6 volte scopriremo che
quelle quattro volte in più è soltanto
uno spreco di energia
Ecco ma 10 e 6 sapete che rapporto è e
1,6 eccetera eccetera molto prossimo a
quell'1,618 e questa è la risposta
dobbiamo far ritornare il pensiero di
Leonardo dobbiamo far ricrescere di
nuovo le piramidi dobbiamo far pensare
in modo di rivedere
Monnalisa o il paesaggio sul Rodano il
titolo di quel libro di quel disegno
Scusate
ma sapete perché Perché ci piacciono che
ci piacciono
natura e la sua armonia è il posto più
bello Dove trascorrere la nostra
Eternità Grazie
[Applauso]